digital capture of the human face from
live actions began almost 20 sorry two
decades ago it is one of the biggest
challenges in VFX but it's continued to
develop only it only brings us closer to
representing the accurate and natural
human expressions in completely digital
characters while to some that's just one
step closer to Skynet's ultimate
dominance over humankind to others its
unending possibility tonight we honor
two groups that are making strides in
the field of facial capture but first is
polarized spherical gradient
illumination and light stage X
tonight the Academy presents a technical
achievement award to pull the Bebek
Timothy Hawkins hwachun MA and showman
you for their work on polar ice vertical
gradient illumination and light stage
acts all right fellas coming up
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You SciTech committee we had a lot
of help developing this technology in
addition to our families
hi mom we'd like to thank Graham Fife
Abhijeet Ghosh
Syrus Wilson J Bush pear Anderson mark
bolus Peter peers
Andy Gardner Charles Felix a bear and
Sebastian sylvan for all of their
contributions we'd like to thank Randy
Hill David Cassone and Kathleen Hass
from USC ICT and Jules Urbach and clay
sparks from Oh toy for supporting the
development and production ization of
this technology and very importantly
we'd like to thank the visual effects
artists and supervisors who led the
creation of groundbreaking digital
characters using light stage facial
scanning including Martin Hill Joel
Atari Steve Rosenbaum mark cigar John
Nelson Darrin handler Steve pragmatist
Whitman Xavier von der Palin srinivasan
Mohan Boyd Sherman subs are gabor Paul
Lambert and Jonathan litt
it's been it's been fantastic crossing
the valley with you thank you very much
[Applause]